Так звучить війна. У Маріуполі її не просто чують здалека - вона на кожному квадратному сантиметрі міста.
Точніше того, що від нього лишилося.
А ще зовсім недавно Маріуполь виглядав ось так.
Півмільйонний порт, "вітрина українського Донбасу".
У 2014 році тут були вуличні бої - вибивали сепаратистів так званої "ДНР".
У 2015 - обстріл східної околиці з "Градів".
Відтоді - тиша і масштабна відбудова.
Хоча лінія фронту за 20 кілометрів від міста не давала людям забути про війну.
Ось що рік тому маріупольці говорили нашим кореспондентам про російську загрозу.
Загроза? Та вона не спадала у нас ніколи, та загроза. Ми були завжди готові.
Так вже у нас, слава Богу, як кажуть у козаків, шашки салом мажемо. Хай приходять.
Маріуполь у небезпеці, це так.
- А ви якось готуєтеся до такого сценарію? Є тривожна валіза?
- Ні, я думаю, що в цьому немає сенсу. Ми це вже пережили. Тривожні валізи не допомагають. Просто тікаєш і все.
З третього березня Маріуполь в блокаді.
Не змогли втекти з міста 350 тисяч людей.
На них щодня скидають по 50-100 бомб.
Для півторарічного Кирила осколкове поранення стало смертельним.
Це одна з небагатьох лікарень, які вціліли.
За словами медиків, на кожного пораненого військового надходять по десять цивільних.
Нині тут і швидка, і пологовий, і морг.
Тому що інші лікарні розбомбили. МНС немає, нікого немає.
Родичі кажуть: "Ми не знаємо, куди ми їх ховати будемо - у братську могилу?".
Гадки не мають. На 17-му районі лікарня не приймає, "швидка" не приймає,
у нас остання територія, куди привозять поранених. Усе, більше немає куди.
Це всі, кого не вдалося врятувати.
До всього звикаєш. Але потім… Увечері з голови не йде.
Для російської армії бої за Маріуполь - це протистояння за важливий порт
і ділянку потенційного "коридору" між так званими "ДНР/ЛНР" і Кримом.
Для тисяч маріупольців - це тижні без світла, тепла, їжі і води.
Заради елементарної потреби - води - люди шукали криниці, топили сніг, спускали воду із систем опалення.
Гуманітарна допомога із Запоріжжя вже майже два тижні не може дістатися Маріуполя через обстріли.
Кількох немовлят матері залишили в цій лікарні, бо тут є електрика від генераторів і мінімальний запас ліків.
Допоможіть, це місто жиле, жилі будинки! SOS!
Допоможіть Маріуполю! Убивають дітей, жінок, лікарні переповнені!
Ми всі тут нащо? Я не можу зрозуміти! Це геноцид!
16 березня ракета влучила в серце Маріуполя - будівлю драмтеатру.
В укритті під спорудою ховалися близько тисячі цивільних.
На асфальті перед театром були великі написи "Діти", помітні з повітря.
Місцева влада згодом повідомила, що укриття витримало.
Але що нині з людьми під завалами - невідомо, адже зв'язку з містом майже немає.
Це сьогодні, на жаль, можна назвати лише одним словом - геноцид нашої нації, нашого українського народу.
Я впевнений, що настане той день, коли ми разом підіймемо з руїн наше прекрасне місто Маріуполь.
Але, на жаль, ми не піднімемо тих, кого забрала ця жахлива війна.
Скільки жителів міста загинуло під час бойових дій підрахувати неможливо.
Заступник мера Сергій Орлов назвав цифру у понад дві тисячі цивільних.
Ще сотні людей - під завалами. За оцінкою Орлова, місто на 90 відсотків зруйновано.
Невідомо, чи зможуть колись відновити роботу два маріупольські промислових гіганти -
металургійні комбінати імені Ілліча й "Азовсталь".
Нині люди залишають місто на свій страх і ризик - під обстрілами.
Їдуть приватними автівками, поки вистачає пального.
З міста Маріуполь виїхали майже 800 приватних автомобілів.
Люди також виходять з міста пішки.
Для всіх, хто виїхав із Маріуполя організовано тимчасові пункти допомоги в Бердянську.
Також завтра такі пункти почнуть діяти і в місті Мангуш.
Усіх людей, які йдуть пішки, будуть довозити з Мангуша до Бердянська.
Тим часом місто-символ українського Донбасу перебуває за межею гуманітарної катастрофи.
Унаслідок бойових дій, за словами місцевої влади, повністю знищене місто Волноваха.
Російські війська також зруйнували інфраструктуру Харкова, Чернігова, Сум, Ізюма, Охтирки
і ще десятків міст і селищ.
Ідеться саме про цивільні об'єкти, а не "військову інфраструктуру", як запевняють у Кремлі.